today Parliament stands empty shut down
by a prime minister running away from
scrutiny but let me say this we mustn't
ever mistake the drama at Westminster
for what real politics is about what
truly matters to people isn't
resignations and defections and late
night votes in Parliament for most
people all of that is a million miles
away what truly matters is the reality
of their everyday lives in their
community on their streets and at their
workplace real politics for me isn't
about the parliamentary knockabout with
all its baffling language and procedures
real politics is about giving power to
people who don't have a lot of money and
don't have friends in high places so
they can take control of their own lives
Boris Johnson's political strategy is
perfectly clear he wants to stage a
showdown over a No Deal brexit that he
can repackage as a battle between
Parliament's and the people with the
people in this melodrama played by none
other than that man of the people Boris
Johnson himself but the idea that
Johnson and his wealthy friends and
backers somehow represent people is
truly absurd Johnson and his right-wing
cabinet are not only on the side of the
establishment they are the establishment
and this story government isn't so
different from any other Tory government
they will help the rich to get richer
and make working-class people pay
Johnson's reckless No Deal would destroy
jobs push up food prices in the shops
and cause shortages of everyday
medicines that people rely on and it
will disrupt supply chains in
manufacturing industry and lead to all
kinds of problems in many other places
of work and who bears the cost of that
it wouldn't be Johnson and his wealthy
friends it's not their livelihoods on
the line it will be the rest of us just
as it wasn't the bankers who Boris
Johnson still defends who paid the price
for the financial crash of 2008 it was
tens of millions of working people who
had absolutely nothing to do with it
for the Tories for the Tories this is
about so much more than leaving the
European Union
it's about hijacking the referendum
results to shift even more power and
wealth to those at the top they will use
a No Deal crash to push through policies
that benefit them and their super-rich
supporters and hurt everyone else just
as they did after the financial crash
under the cover of No Deal
they will sell off our public services
strip away the regulations that keep us
safe and undermine workers rights and
they will cement all of this in a race
to the bottom trade deal with Donald
Trump be in no doubt a No Deal brexit is
really a Trump deal brexit
which will lead to a one-sided United
States trade deal negotiated from a
position of weakness it will put us at
the mercy of Trump and the big US
corporations itching absolutely edging
to get their teeth even further into our
National Health Service